juste je veux dire, c'est presque l'un de mes
favoris instantanés
[Musique]
n'est-ce pas
c'est [
Musique] de
minuscules petites lettres découpées
et c'est tout, je me sens énormément,
euh privilégié que les gens partagent
ces choses avec moi et je peux  Je ne peux pas
croire que
je ne peux pas croire que tout cela, comme celui des
gens,
tu connais le monde intérieur des gens et
tu sais et tous les efforts qu'ils ont
déployés pour me les envoyer,
tu le sais et je sens que je ressens  un sentiment
d'obligation de les partager,
c'est peut-être le plus gentil que nous ayons eu depuis
longtemps.
J'ai un secret que je veux partager avec le
monde. Mon fils est sorti confiné à l'âge de 18 ans.
Je suis la maman la plus chanceuse du monde.
avoir un fils gay,
devrais-je le faire ouais, euh,
n'est-ce pas si beau
[Musique]
que
intéressant de voir en fait
combien il y en a de chaque thème et ainsi
vous pouvez vraiment commencer à
voir comment  le verrouillage a commencé
à affecter, je veux dire, je pense que vous pouvez et
je veux dire, je pense que c'est une vraie
étude, quelqu'un pourrait les étudier
et vraiment arriver à des
conclusions assez intéressantes sur
notre état mental et notre renversement. J'ai triché
à un
quiz zoom et je regrette  rien d'aussi brillant
[Applaudissements]
c'est ce que je trouve de si étonnant
chez eux, c'est qu'ils ont passé le
confinement 1.0 enfermé, c'était l'expérience la plus
terrifiante de ma vie